hi and welcome to my video series of
pyrotechnics explained in five minutes
where I explain a concept in biology in
less than 5 minute so if you haven't yet
subscribed to my channel please hit that
subscribe button in this installment
we'll be talking about DNA's
footprinting si now DNS printing si is
used to determine DNA protein
interaction it could be also used to
understand whether a particular protein
is a transcription factor or a DNA
binding has a DNA binding element or not
so the principle is fairly simple it is
based on the principle that if a protein
is binding to a DNA and it would protect
that segment of DNA where it binds from
any kind of dnase digestion right so
let's just try to take an example and
try to understand that but before that
you have to understand why it is called
footprinting so if you are walking in a
sandy beach and you would leave your
footprint on the beach so your footprint
would be kind of a proof that you have
walked on that sandy beach right as if
when protein binds into the DNA let's
say a transcription factor or a
polymerase it kind of leaves its
footprint on the DNA that's weird right
don't worry we will take an example and
try to understand let's see here is a
transcription factor which can aid in
transcription now in order to be a
transcription factor the first and
foremost criteria is it has to bind with
the DNA now imagine it has bind with DNA
and there is another situation there is
no protein bound to our DNA so there are
two kind of comparable situation so here
there is no protein bound to the DNA and
if we treat it with TNS digestion in
several kind of iteration the DNA's
would cleave the DNA fragment and we can
get a variety of fragment of variable
length now if you run that in a jail we
would have several band of different
different sizes because you can see in
this small lane of these gel now let's
say a second situation
protein which we are suspecting to be a
transcription factor is bound to the DNA
and we are also digesting that Ginebra
bound that the protein bound DNA with
our DNA's enzyme now it would cut in
several different location but it cannot
cut in the location where the protein is
bound now if we run that same fragments
in the gel we would see fragments in all
particular locations except in a
location you would see no bands the
location where we see no bands that is
the footprint of the protein on the DNA
it also tells us that the sequence if we
compare it with the no protein control
we can understand which sequence our
protein of interest has found with the
DNA that would in turn tell us that in
this particular sequence our protein of
interest has bound and left its
footprint and this is the goal of DNS
footprinting si
a simple si cost-effective but even very
elegant
even this si is used these days to
understand the inner protein interaction
so if you liked this video
very good thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you